hi there steve here
um if you're interested in language
learning please subscribe to my channel
i have another channel where i talk
about politics
and
both of these channels the videos the
audio the transcript are available as
lessons at link please check in the
description box today i want to talk
about output because i had a question
from one of my viewers about swain's
output theory
or hypothesis so i looked that up and
because i wasn't aware of it and
basically what swain says is that
we learn from output
uh because output enables us to identify
our gaps
gaps between what we want to say and
what we're able to say second of all
output has a hypothesis testing function
when a learner says something there is a
tacit hypothesis underlying his
utterances about grammar in other words
we test whether we know the grammar it's
kind of like the same as finding our
gaps i don't quite see the difference
and the third thing is a meta-linguistic
function learners reflect on the
language they learn are and thereby they
the output enables them to control and
internalize linguistic knowledge to me
it's all the same yeah we need output
and and the issue with output to me is
it's a question of how much output when
and traditional language instruction
puts a lot of emphasis on output and
correct output at an early stage teacher
teaches something and you've got to
reproduce it and produce it correctly
and i think that's
wrong
because
my experience has been that until i've
had a lot of the language brought into
me
that it's very difficult to remember
things it's very difficult to get the
structure right and so a very minimal
amount of output in the initial stages
is enough besides which output at the
initial stage can be quite stressful
because you can't say anything
long silences
you comment on the weather over and over
again
and the other thing is
any
output implies
an engagement with someone so you can't
just output without having
you know a conversation coming back at
you and if you don't understand what's
being said you can't have a meaningful
conversation so for those reasons i'm
not a big fan of speaking at an early
stage and the fact is that
input reading and listening and paying
attention is so powerful as a way of
ingesting getting the language in you
learning it's faster in my opinion than
speaking because
at an early stage if all you all the
words you are using are the words that
you are able to use you are going to
have a very limited amount of the
language that you are engaging with
whereas with listening and reading you
can engage with much more of the
language and it's easier to organize and
carry with you and so forth and so on
but at a certain point for sure you need
to speak and you need to speak a lot and
so and when you do speak later on you do
identify your gaps you see which
structures you aren't able to use which
words you aren't able to find so this is
extremely valuable however
the i would say the language density and
the intensity and the quantity of words
etc that you deal with
when you are engaged in in meaningful
input and listening to and reading
things of interest is much greater than
what you can do in in an output exercise
so i have conversations i spoke checked
for an hour yesterday i spoke russian
for an hour today and i think that you
know a few hours a week is of output in
other words conversation is plenty then
i receive my report from my link tutor i
go over the words that i had trouble
with and all of this helps me to notice
things in my listening and reading but
if i have say in a given language call
it either czech or russian or polish
whatever if i have a couple of hours per
week of output that's enough but i might
have a couple of a couple of hours or an
hour to two hours a day of input
activity and i think that's primarily
price that's the biggest part of my
learning and eventually as i progress
obviously i want to do more and more
output output and if i had the
opportunity to travel to the country
where the language is spoken then i
could spend a lot more time with output
so output is important
swain's hypothesis
kind of splits hairs in a way
but still
input over output input before output
input more than output that's my take on
it look forward to hearing from you bye
for now
you